il était très pipi caca un été en été il
est tombé en extase devant une énorme
crotte en plein soleil tu étais couverte
de mouches vous savez et il me disait
mais regardez comme c'est beau mais
regardez
maintenant à mon avis
[Applaudissements]
sur ce plateau c'était en compagnie de
l'amiral Philippe De Gaulle oui mon
frère
à qui j'avais demandé quelle femme il
souhaitait avoir avec lui ce soir-là
vous êtes revu depuis
non non c'est c'est fini on est resté là
mais je plais beaucoup aux hommes
politiques
cette rencontre et il en pense souvent
imprégner
vous plaisez beaucoup aux vieux vous
plaît aussi beaucoup aux jeunes
on va parler de Salvador Dali après
l'amiral de Gaulle ça fait quand même
alors vous publiez chez Michel Lafont
vous aussi un livre qui s'appelle
mondali à l'occasion du centenaire de la
naissance de Salvador Dali en 1904 voilà
alors au-delà de la caricature
généralement véhiculé par les médias
c'est à dire le je suis fou du chocolat
Lanvin l'anagramme de son nom à vida
dollar voilà vous essayez de montrer un
Dali un peu plus vrai le mot réhabiliter
mais c'est vrai que d'aller souffre
d'une très mauvaise image on se rappelle
de lui en effet la caricature le type
qui voulait choquer le provocateur les
moustaches rigolotes etc on oublie un
petit peu que c'était quand même un
peintre fantastique un dessinateur
incroyable et puis surtout un génie et
alors c'est sa faute de toute façon
comme tous les gens qui aiment provoquer
Gainsbourg pareil quand il voulait les
billets ils savent très bien qu'en
provoquant ils vont se faire taper
dessus mais c'est plus fort que il peut
pas s'en empêcher pareil ma fille
souvent la provocation ça va il peut il
sait pas où il peut s'arrêter et donc
Dali était comme ça et je le déploie
parce que moi j'ai connu un Dali l'être
humain avec ses faiblesses
son humour et tout et non pas l'homme
public l'homme public moi il m'était
franchement antipathique c'est vrai que
Dali l'homme public c'est pas c'est tout
ce que j'ai testé moi je voyais ce mec
avec une limousine un chauffeur qui
dépensait des fortunes etc
à l'époque et ça me choquait beaucoup
c'était penser mais 68 et tout ça tu
arrêtes de te poudrer la foufoune oui et
c'est vrai
et donc en rencontrant Dali
et comment ça va
imagine que moi après je vais me mettre
ça sur le nez
je me retrouve plein de boutons voilà la
semaine prochaine avec tes [ __ ]
alors Amanda votre livre parle de Dali
mais au-delà de Dali vous racontez deux
époques absolument fabuleuses d'abord
c'est le swing London les années 60 à
Londres avec les Beatles les Stones
Brian Ferry David Bowie et les années 70
à New York avec quoi rôle Paloma Picasso
Diane de Furstenberg donc c'est un livre
qui est à la fois raconte un grand
peintre et en même temps trace le
portail d'une époque c'est bien
ce n'est pas ma biographie de Dali mais
comme Dali connaissait le monde entier
c'est vrai que à travers lui j'ai
rencontré des gens jamais je n'aurais
espéré même croisé dans la rue commence
en 65 quand vous rencontrez Salvador
Dali vous êtes tous les deux en train de
pisser chez Castel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il était très pipi caca
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tout de suite non une échographie ou dès
qu'on passe en direct mais vous avez un
médecin ici qui peut équiper
est-ce que vous êtes prêtes à vous faire
examiner par un médecin à la télévision
[Applaudissements]
Dali donc vous êtes avec votre fiancée
de l'époque et irlandais qui s'appelle
Tara et en compagnie de Brian Jones
c'est donc vous vous rencontrez saveur
Dali à l'époque il se fait appeler le
divin le divin d'Alice il donne des
surnoms à tout le monde sauf à vous
parce qu'il vous a appelé tout le temps
il ne retenez pas le nom des gens
c'était impossible pour lui donc c'est
toujours approximatif c'est pas Rosine
Bachelot il y aurait des cachaloé
à la sonorité comme ça je dis bah je
mets ça pour être il a rencontré Sylvie
Vartan il est incapable se rappeler si
il leur temps il a appelé Cécile
Bertrand parce que la sonorité c'était
un petit peu ça et donc il préférait
donner des surnoms
par air descend il pouvait pas se
rappeler Ardisson alors
non il aurait dit police
14 il y avait une dame blonde avec des
cheveux très bouclés très imposantes
plein de bijoux il disait c'est le roi
Louis XIV il appelait Louis XIV donc il
parlait tout le monde comme ça au
masculin et je dois dire que ça prêtait
beaucoup à confusion déjà à l'époque
alors au début vous le trouvez quand
même à moitié chaud il a un peu grave
vous le trouvez un peu ridicule au
départ non
à peu prèstentieux vous pensez qu'à
l'époque moi je j'étais très attirée par
les chanteurs rock et les guitaristes et
tout ça donc c'était mon truc c'était
plutôt les mecs avec des cheveux blancs
et tout et je vois ce monsieur qui était
plutôt antipathique avec des moustaches
envoyé un kilomètre qui se maquillent en
plus avec du crayon noir et tout quand
il m'a embrassé porte et ça Moussa j'ai
resté imprimé ça c'est rien tu vois
après
et donc c'est vrai qu'il m'a pas paru
trop sympa et en plus de ça c'était pas
mon problème préféré et j'adorais
Picasso et pas du tout la peinture de
Dali alors évidemment tout le monde se
demande est-ce que vous êtes tapé Dali
et il y a des révélations dans votre
bouquin il était en fait fasciné par les
prouesses sexuelles de sa cour mais lui
d'après ce qu'on comprend c'est qu'il
était impuissant en fait des voyeurs
quoi ils regardent il était tout le
temps de chercher des filles pour poser
pour lui alors quand on a une très jolie
fille et qu'on lui dit voulez-vous vous
déshabiller mademoiselle entièrement nue
pour la rassurer évidemment la fille se
dit va me sauter dessus c'est un vieux
cochon donc on peut le rassurer il était
toujours assuré je suis impuissant de
toute façon et alors ça rassurait les
filles donc il disait tout le temps je
suis impuissant mais enfin les gens qui
le disent tout le temps tu sais c'est
quand même bizarre et on s'est aperçu
petit à petit qu'on fait il était pas
vraiment impuissant il aimait bien se
donner cette image et il était surtout
très cérébral comme beaucoup d'artistes
tout son génie c'était c'était pas
l'acte physique tripoter quelqu'un qui
est intéressé c'était tout ça pendant
j'en profite pour vous palper un petit
peu ma fille il y a longtemps
[Rires]
la place non alors votre première
rencontre il vous demande si vous êtes
lesbienne oui ça aussi ça l'intéressait
beaucoup comme il était un peu voyeur il
aimait bien savoir que les filles
étaient lesbiennes entre elles les mecs
[ __ ] et cetera ça alors moi je dis tout
ça ça m'intéresse pas moi tous ces trucs
là c'est c'est pas
homoteur
était amoureux de lui et Dali avait pas
dit non d'ailleurs mais ça lui avait
fait mal
[Rires]
sodomie avait été arrêtée à mi-parcours
au début pareil ça fait très mal je sais
pas la première fois Amanda Alzheimer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
fétichiste il adoré vos pieds par
exemple
surréaliste les bottines lacets tous ces
trucs là
il y a des titres
[Applaudissements]
et il aimait beaucoup quelqu'un
s'appelait gérardit
avec une serviette il se transformait en
pharaon extraordinaire qui se souvient
de Gérard City chez vous il a joué dans
Van Gogh tu t'en souviens
bravo Serge voilà et donc alors oui il y
a une histoire extraordinaire donc c'est
que Dali était marié avec Gala la
fameuse gala évidemment et alors la
première rencontre il vous vend à elle
comme un aspirateur il dit elle est
formidable c'est au nom de l'époque elle
a des longs cheveux elle a les mains et
c'était très important pour lui que
Gallame accepte parce que c'était la
femme légitime il allait pas le dire
j'ai rencontré une fille super je
voudrais qu'elle vienne vivre à la
maison bon c'était mal barré donc il m'a
dit il faut que vous fassiez bonne
impression alors moi j'ai fait un effort
je me suis maquillé bien tout ça et
quand je vous ai présenté à Gala c'était
le pire évidemment parce que il arrêtait
pas de regarder regarde ma petite chérie
regarde comment elle est belle tournez
vous en attendant vous faites voir vos
jambes et que là elle tirer une tronche
plus d'aller comme un aspirateur mais je
vous assure elle est vraiment très bien
puis elle est très intelligente tu
verras puis elle parle plusieurs langues
égal à de plus en plus elle disait mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette gonzesse
et tout ça non non c'était c'était pas
bien du tout ça vous mangez beaucoup
lors de ce premier dîner
gala dit qu'est-ce qu'elle mange alors
politesse et elle a cette phrase
terrible elle dit si vous étiez poli
vous viendriez pas chez moi avec une
mini jupe qui montre tout quoi c'était à
l'époque de Marie Cointe et des
mini-jupe donc moi j'avais
une autre culotte aura de la foufoune et
envoyer
et égal à tout ça non c'est c'est pas
fait bonne impression là c'est la
première fois ça a pas été terrible ce
qui est très sympathique de la part de
gala c'est que finalement elle part en
voyage et elle elle vous donne à Dali me
disait mais moi j'aime mon mari elle
folle de son mari et mon mari est
heureux avec Amanda voilà je suis
heureuse pour mon mari
c'est énorme ça c'est énorme
qui détestait les femmes qui faisaient
de la peinture parce qu'il disait que le
génie est dans les couilles et comme
peinture mais non le talent justement
chez les messieurs résident là-dedans et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs il disait
qu'ils sont impuissants ils ne font pas
des enfants on peut pas faire des
enfants quand on est Michel-Ange ou
Léonard de Vinci donc tout ça est
sublimé et ça te sort par ton pinceau
exactement ce que je voulais éviter ça
s'appelle
et alors il y a une révélation dans
votre bouquin c'est qu'en fait ce Dali
il avait un [ __ ] qui recopiait les
photos pour les parties réalise des
tableaux que ça plaît
il y a des parties un peu chiantes à
faire le fond le ciel et tout comme ça
donc Béa était un bras petit artisan qui
faisait ça très bien et puis d'aller
après arriver alors il mettait les
touches géniales etc mais j'ai beaucoup
appris j'ai beaucoup appris en le
regardant
tout le monde très mal ça c'est vrai il
faut le dire il était pas très gentil
avec ses collaborateurs dans la vie
quotidienne par exemple nettoyer jamais
ses lunettes
elles étaient très sale et comme il
était très coquet souvent il voulait pas
mettre ses lunettes on les voyait pas
grand chose vu son âge et par exemple
dans les taxis pour pas mettre ses
lunettes quand il y avait à New York au
compteur il sortait des billets de 100
dollars et il donnait au chauffeur le
chauffeur et 100 dollars 200 dollars 300
dollars il y avait écrit 3 dollars 50 et
350 dollars et le chauffeur disait thank
you Mr les God blessés alors moi j'ai
tout capté à Gala et elle a arrêté de
lui donner de l'argent
des tricots de corps sale qui empilaient
les uns sur les autres le matin il
aimait beaucoup prendre son petit
déjeuner en tricot de corps et alors il
faisait tomber il tremper son croissant
dans du miel et alors le miel
dégoulinait un petit peu sur son truc et
un peu des tâches de café au lait
aussi il en mettait un propre mais
gardez le sale toujours en dessous parce
que il aimait bien regarder les tâches
il était fasciné par les excréments par
rapport à la pourriture par exemple un
soir ils vont dîner chez un ami de Dali
il s'appelle plat il y avait des traces
extrêmement sur la cuvette il a passé la
soirée à vous dire
les traces de merde sur les chiottes il
était très pipi caca en été il est tombé
en extase devant une énorme crotte en
plein soleil qui était couverte de
mouches vous savez et il me disait mais
regardez comme c'est beau mais regardez
alors moi je disais bon ben ça va on
continue mais non mais non mais regardez
alors il regardait les ailes des mouches
la couleur irisée c'était assez
répugnant mais évidemment
point de vue il faut penser que c'était
un peintre et je pense que PEF a du
talent parce que moi maintenant je dois
révéler une chose c'est que quand on a
écrit notre première pièce Robin des
Bois d'à peu près Alexandre Dumas on
écrivait chez moi dans ma cuisine et un
jour paix façonner et comme
c'est important de savoir mais comme il
avait pas eu de m'acheter des fleurs il
m'avait amené une crotte gelée dans un
barrage
de pouvoir prendre une crotte congelée
quoi c'est incroyable non une crotte
contre ça va mieux le psy qu'est-ce
qu'il en est
il est confiant en fait vous étiez très
amoureuse de Dali simplement vous l'avez
connu 40 ans trop tard quoi c'est ça
c'est ben oui oui c'est vrai je l'aurais
posé
parce que il était fascinant il était
cultivé il savait tout il avait des
anecdotes invraisemblable il me
racontait je sais pas ces rencontres
avec Hitchcock avec Walt Disney avec
Marilyn Monroe il avait connu le mentir
donc moi j'étais fasciné là maintenant
je parle beaucoup mais à l'époque je
disais rien moi j'écoutais et c'était
comme ça on les pousse tout de suite il
était aussi très possessif parce que
quand vous êtes avec David Bowie par
exemple il vous envoie
ce mec il se maquille plus que vous et
non il y avait pas beau oui enfin ça
allait se couper il vient le côté gore
le côté tout ça vous racontez aussi
cette déchéance et dernière fois que que
vous le voyez en 1983 il refuse de
pouvoir dans la lumière il veut vous
voir dans le noir on s'est rencontré
dans le noir total il ne voulait plus
que je le vois alors ça va très bien
qu'il était on a vu les photos elle
mouille Newton un tuyau dans le nez tout
ça il y avait un certain exhibitionniste
moi-même à se faire voir se donner tout
le temps en spectacle même mourant et
malade et tout mais vis-à-vis de moi il
avait il avait honte que je le vois
comme ça il disait je veux que vous
rappeler toujours de moi très beau parce
qu'il pensait
pas très beau très fringants et donc on
s'est rentré dans le noir complet et
c'était assez émouvant et puis après ça
il a fini bien tristement comme tous ces
gens qui n'ont pas d'enfants il est il
est mort tout seul entouré de deux gens
qui voulaient faire du pognon Dali a
disparu aujourd'hui si vous étiez la
muse d'un peintre vous voudriez être la
muse de quel peintre je ne sais pas si
aujourd'hui il y en a qui me fascine
autant parce que tous ceux qui
[Applaudissements]
va vous faire une interview déjà dit
déjà dit allez
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit déjà dit
désolé c'était ma dernière paire en 48
[Rires]
on me dit souvent désolé c'était ma
dernière paire en 41 parce que je fais
du 41 c'est pas est-ce que vous êtes
déjà dit toi ma chérie tu as les yeux
qui crient braguette
non mais c'est une bonne expression
est-ce que vous a déjà dit ça vous
dérange pas que ma femme regarde
oui mais ça ça me plaît pas du tout
est-ce que vous avez déjà dit ça vous
dérange pas que ma mère regarde
ma maman est-ce que vous avez déjà dit
ça vous dérange pas si je demande à mes
potes de nous rejoindre oui ça mais de
plus en plus on dit ça parce que ça
c'est pas passé c'est nouveau cette
histoire de d'échangisme de tous les
copains ensemble alors moi qui suis
plutôt pas partageuse c'est pas mon truc
ça mais c'est vrai que c'est de plus en
plus est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit merci
pour cette nuit mais désolé il faut que
j'y aille j'ai un conseil des ministres
ah oui oui dans le regard oui oui trop
tard non pas un conseil des ministres on
me dit des fois j'ai un concert où j'ai
une Stade de France
est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit c'est quoi
ces prix exorbités
est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit appelle-moi
Benito ça m'excite
même Berlusconi je suis pas du tout une
jambe
il est très belle fille d'ailleurs
italienne très traditionnelle c'est la
la belle italienne vient pulpeuse avec
des poils sur les bras et tout c'est pas
du tout moi je sais pas du tout son
genre du tout donc est-ce que vous avez
déjà dit eh mais c'est pas mes couilles
ça
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu